conquest in battlefield 1942 Titan in
battlefield 2142 rush in Battlefield Bad
Company 2 there are certain game modes
that seem to define each installment of
battlefields to be the experiences that
players gravitate towards and remember
most vividly with another beta of
battlefield hardline now upon us we're
getting our hands on what I think will
be the signature mode for this entry in
the series Hotwire now hear me out
Hotwire is basically conquest with cars
instead of static points around the map
that each team assaults and defends over
the course of the match there are cars
to capture the point and bleed tickets
from the opposing team you need to get
into the car and drive it above a
certain speed when you slow down or stop
no more capture and when the car blows
up it responds quickly this mobility
makes Hotwire different from conquests
in a few key ways first in order to be
gaining points you have to be actively
driving the car
so no more bleeding tickets just because
the other team hasn't bothered to
recapture that deserted point out in the
boondocks and no more lying and wait out
in the boondocks racking up the XP for
holding the point but actually bored out
of your skull because no one's around in
Hotwire you can't rely on the other
teams passivity to keep a point bleeding
tickets is always an active endeavor
second to capture a point from the enemy
team you have to lure them out of the
car or just blow the thing up entirely
the sneaky infiltration the air drop the
vehicle rush the multi squad Normandy
style onslaught and other tried and true
conquest tactics are pretty much out the
window instead you have the car chase in
which you pack into a car with your
buddies hanging out the window and try
to run them down like crazy vigilantes
you have the ambush in which you get to
an elevated position over a central road
and equip a grenade launcher or put down
breaching charges in the road maybe
parking a car to block the road for good
measures you have the helicopter
pursuits the solo maniac run them off
the road attack the straight-up carjack
or the sabotage in which you use the
mechanics nuke it item to plant a car
bomb under the capture
Carr lying wait and then watch your
enemy try to speed away and
ba-ba-ba-boom all of these tactics don't
just require execution they require
anticipation and planning and okay
sometimes you just get lucky and someone
runs up on you but still the
destructibility and mobility of the
capture points to make this mode feel
dynamic and invigorating of course
Hotwire isn't without its downsides or
potential issues there was a match or
two when I was just cruising this one
loop for minutes and minutes totally
killing it on points but kind of wishing
someone would come mess with me
the driving mechanics are pretty solid
but you couldn't really call them
enjoyable in and of themselves
eventually cruised into the danger zone
just to live a little you know it's also
worth noting that I've only played a few
hours of Hotwire and as we all know the
game changes significantly once tons of
people start playing it figuring out
strategies and counters and generally
being really good at stuff it's possible
that folks will figure out how to kill
cars at will or that helicopters will
just rain terror overall from the jet
'less skies but I still think Hotwire
will succeed because conquest never
really had an answer for the nervous
energy that most players bring to the
game for every cool headed sniper or
stalwart lone defender there were entire
squads of dudes just running from point
to point
capturing and then deserting them
because they didn't want to sit still
they wanted to be where the action was
well there's no sitting still in Hotwire
and I think the frenetic Vaughn of
speeding around in mobile capture points
is just the thing for the boisterous
belligerent energies of battlefield
players
one down